the Acting Secretary of Homeland
Security Elaine Duke is going to Puerto
Rico today to meet with hurricane
victims the FBI is investigating claims
of possible fraud in connection with
hurricane supplies food and other items
are allegedly being diverted from Puerto
Ricans who need them David Beck know is
in caravanners Puerto Rico as president
Trump waiting again this morning on the
US territories financial problems David
good morning good morning president
Trump tweeted that Congress needs to
decide how much to spend in terms of
helping Puerto Rico rebuild mr. Trump
went on to tweet that FEMA the military
and first responders who've been amazing
under the most difficult circumstances
cannot stay in Puerto Rico forever based
on our reporting people here are not
asking for forever they're asking for
things to get better right now words are
not necessary to describe Martina
Rivera's
he left me she saw her husband Jorge
died Friday
doctors say he contracted a bacterial
disease known as leptospirosis complete
gall he was initially diagnosed with
dengue and sent home according to his
daughter Joanna her older sister Evelyn
says the last thing she told her father
is I love you three other people are
suspected of dying from the disease it
spread through contaminated water but
easily treatable with antibiotics it's
been three weeks taken so long so that's
the island Secretary of State Luis
Rivera Miren he says the governor
ordered him to figure out why clean
water is not getting to every part of
this island at what point do you bypass
the local government if they're not
getting it done and at what point do you
guys do it we've been doing it that's
why being we've been even doing air
drops in communities where we go
directly to isolated communities where a
bridge has been destroyed by the water
or any reason which needs us to impact
them directly we'll keep doing that
three weeks after the hurricane the
government is now handing out 1 million
water purifying tablets as well as
20,000 high volume water filters
back at the garden of God Pentecostal
church the widow sobs why was he taken
away this morning's iOpener in it that
was David beg no reporting from Puerto
Rico really rough to hear that story but
he's done some great reporting